être esclave de la modernité être
esclave de cette petite icône sur vos
téléphones peut avoir des répercussions
dangereuses sur votre quotidien ce n'est
pas moi qui le dit mais bien facebook
lui-même une étude interne reprise par
le wall street journal révèle qu'un
utilisateur sur 8 déclarent faire un
usage ou pulls cif du réseau social les
conséquences sont nombreuses et des
fastes pour la santé commençons par un
fait simple vous êtes dans votre livre
vous ne trouvez pas le sommeil premier
réflexe prendre son smartphone appuyé
sur son application le et faire défiler
le fil d'actu c'est ce qu'on appelle du
sommeil heures mois est automatiquement
une perte de productivité le lendemain
que ce soit au travail ou pour toute
autre activité autre exemple démontré
par cette étude
la dégradation des relations
personnelles c'est à dire remplacer le
temps passé ensemble par des heures
voire plus en ligne
la ville famille s'en trouve fortement
impactée notamment pour les parents dans
certains cas les parents se concentrer
davantage sur facebook que sur les soins
apportés ou à la communication avec
leurs enfants les effets pervers de
l'utilisation à outrance du réseau
social dans la maison mère s'appelle
désormais meta concernerait près de 360
millions d'utilisateurs dans le monde
ces nouvelles révélations s'inscrivent
dans la lignée des facebook files des
articles basés sur des documents
internes fournis par la lanceuse d'alert
française à google cet ancien employé du
département et civique integrity chargée
de lutter contre l'effet que news
montrent que meta consacre davantage de
ressources à limiter ses effets néfastes
en occident au détriment du reste du
monde des conséquences connues en
interne mais les signaux d'alerté ne
sont pas toujours pris en compte en
témoigne cette étude de 2010 est réalisé
par une équipe axée sur le bien-être
cette même équipe avait suggéré des
solutions pour limiter ces usages
problématiques
mais cette section était dissoute par à
mark zuckerberg en 2019 ces usages le
wall street journal n'a pas peur des
mots il est qualifié de dépendance un
terme qui fait bondir le groupe une
utilisation problématique n'est pas
synonyme de dépendances le wall street
journal a de nouveau choisi de manier
sélective des documents internes de
l'entreprise pour présenter un récit qui
est tout simplement faux sur la façon
dont nous utilisons la recherche pour
aborder un problème important notre
entreprise s'est engagée et soutient les
efforts à plusieurs niveaux pour mieux
comprendre et responsabiliser les
personnes qui utilisent nos services
pour gérer les utilisations
problématique en pleine tourmente meta
doit affronter bon nombre de révélations
depuis plus d'un mois dans la presse
gestion discrétionnaire des profils vip
non soumis aux mêmes règles que les
autres effets pervers des algorithmes de
recommandation ou encore cette
accusation de privilégier le profit à la
santé des utilisateurs
une affaire dont 100 par les
parlementaires aux états unis et
ailleurs français saoudienne mène ce
combat elle vole d'une audition à
l'autre après washington londres le
parlement européen ce lundi elle sera ce
mercredi à l'assemblée et au sénat signe
d'une véritable prise de conscience de
la part des politiques
je suis heureuse que l'union européenne
prenne cette question très au sérieux
le digital services act qui est
actuellement examiné par le parlement a
le potentiel pour devenir une référence
mondiale ça peut inspirer d'autres pays
dont le mien à prendre en charge de
nouvelles prérogatives afin de protéger
nos démocraties
français saoudienne va même plus loin
dans son analyse
la lanceuse dallaire considère que les
ingénieurs de facebook ne sont même plus
en mesure de gérer les changements
d'algorithme du réseau social comme si
la créature échapper à son créateur une
métaphore pleine de sens reprise par de
nombreux médias et tout cela était
pourtant prévisible quand on se souvient
du scandale cambridge analytica en 2018
cette firme de marketing politique avait
été accusé d'avoir volé les données de
87 millions d'utilisateurs de facebook
pour tenter de les influencer par des
messages pro trump ou pro ben brik site
un signal d' alerte pas toujours pris en
compte par les politiques à l'époque
aujourd'hui la donne a changé et urgent
c'est de comprendre les effets
systémiques des réseaux sociaux en
général et de facebook en particulier
reste à savoir si ce n'est pas trop tard